marmite et coquemar de villers les pots
piché et cruche de ce vrai ou mouton et
pot de montmuzard tous ces objets sur le
résultat de fouilles dans la région
réalisé dans les dix dernières années
c'est donc la première fois qu'ils sont
exposés ainsi dans un musée l'idée était
justement de montrer au public le
résultat de ses recherches et la variété
de la production locale
comment à chaque période à un moment
donné il y avait eu quelque part une
rencontre entre une matière donc la
terre
une forme un usage mais aussi une
technique
explications et dessin permet de
resituer les objets dans leur contexte
d'époque et incite aussi à regarder
attentivement ces objets si quotidien
comme cette série de cruche piché et pau
créé par la poterie de sevrey en saône
et loire entre le 10e et le xiième
siècle on a un pot qui a la foi peut
être imperméable peut être utilisés dans
le transport stockage sur le feu on a
des pots des poids tout faire et qui
présente voilà de très bonnes
caractéristiques pour l'usagé même si
notre regard de contemporains malgré
finalement peut-être leur leur aspect
assez design a longtemps été jugé
jugé grossier certaines céramique après
l'exposition feront d'ailleurs l'objet
de nouvelles analyses pour mieux
connaître leur histoire leur technique
voir ce qu'elles ont contenu
[Musique]